[MUSIC PLAYING]
[WHIRRING]
MAN: Those are smaller, like--
[ENGINE REVVING]
KIRK ROBINSON: Princeton
Racing Electric
is a student organization where
we are building, designing,
and eventually will be
competing with an electric
high-performance vehicle.
BEN SORKIN: The competition
has about a 200-page rule book
with very, very detailed rules.
And when you get
to the competition,
you have to pass an onsite
electrical inspection
and an onsite
technical inspection.
And they go -- the inspectors
are very, very, very stringent
with these rules.
And if you mess up one
little thing, you're out.
You have time to fix it.
But often, if something goes
wrong, it takes more time.
Out of nearly 30
teams, only three teams
passed all inspections to
be able to run and compete.
KIRK ROBINSON: We ended up
finishing, completing a car,
and went to competition with it.
We did not pass
technical inspection.
BEN SORKIN: We have a couple
months until the competition.
The things that drives the
entire team toward success
is the intersection between
passion and sustainability.
We're doing research and
innovation for a sustainable
energy future.
The car that we're
designing right now
is going to do zero to 60
in about 3 seconds, which
is on par with some of the
fastest production gas cars.
So we're really showing
that sustainable research
is the future.
And we're trying to be at the
forefront of that technology.
And we can't wait for May.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[MACHINE BUZZING]
ASHLEY BARNES: We have all of
these things, all these tools,
like, at our disposal.
I guess it's not a usual thing
that you would get at home
or if you're trying to
do this anywhere else.
It's really nice that we
have almost everything
you need in the one
spot or two spots
and, like, all the different
machines that we have.
[MACHINE WHIRRING]
TARIK DZANIC: I
started designing
steering systems,
the new suspension
system, the brake
systems, like the things
that were a problem in
last year's car. This year,
we are going with a brand new
steering system, new U-joints,
like custom steering
wheel, a new steering
rack, a pedal box that was
pretty much all machined
by hand.
It was mostly like about
20, 25 hours a week
of design or machine work.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
KIRK ROBINSON: The first steps
of getting the car up here
were -- well, it was eventful.
At the end, it turned into
a bit of a sort of mad dash
where we had parts that
were basically lost in labs
and locked into labs that
we couldn't get access to.
So now, we are in the garages
at the New Hampshire Motor
Speedway.
It's cold.
It's rainy.
But it's great to be here.
And it's been a lot of fun.
BEN SORKIN: So far we've passed
pre-electrical inspection.
We have passed
mechanical inspection.
We've passed the
documentation part
of full electrical inspection.
And we're preparing now for the
final electrical inspection.
[CLANGING]
It is currently
Wednesday, so -- is it?
SPEAKER: It's one of them.
BEN SORKIN: What day is it?
It's Wednesday.
It's currently W-- so
it's currently Wednesday.
We've been here for --
this is our third day.
KIRK ROBINSON: I slept
two hours last night.
I slept for five hours
the night before that
and didn't sleep before that.
If we don't pass
inspection -- I mean,
tomorrow is the last
event -- we go home.
It would be very unfortunate
because I know that we're
really, really close.
We haven't had any major
issues of things gone wrong.
JASPER GEBHARDT: It would
definitely be disappointing.
But at this point, we've
put in a lot of work,
and we've come so much further
than I think a lot of us
thought we could have.
So it would be
disappointing, yes.
But it would not be -- I
mean, it would be more
looking forward to next year
and what we can do next year.
KIRK ROBINSON: Nothing's been
sort of a huge, you know,
hugely incorrect.
We have no big disasters.
It has just been a long
list of small tasks.
And all those small
tasks have just sort of
added up into a lot of time.
It's just fighting the clock.
INSPECTOR 1: So the scenario is
there's a dangling wire.
Someone wants to investigate
the dangling wire,
maybe because it was
dangling onto the driver
and they want to pull
it off the driver.
They say, oh, the lights are off.
It's safe for me
to grab the wire
and pull it off the driver.
As they're grabbing
it, it resets.
MAN: It resets.
INSPECTOR 2: And
the lights come on,
and they know they're
being electrocuted.
[BUZZ]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
COLEMAN MERCHANT: Well,
so most of the things
that they called us out on
are directly, like, do this.
There's only the latches
that aren't working --
MAN: The latch is the only one --
COLEMAN MERCHANT: --that
need to be figured out,
so the time is indeterminate.
But other than that,
it's good, so as long
as that doesn't
prove too difficult.
KIRK ROBINSON: Yep.
We'll see.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
BEN SORKIN: So it's
been a long night.
We're close to passing the
final electrical inspection.
But we're having
a few small issues
that we're working to
rectify, some programming
and some physical wiring.
But we do a couple hours,
so I'm still hopeful.
But we'll see.
INSPECTOR 3: Before we
get to the demonstration,
I'm going to just
[INAUDIBLE] .
MAN: You mean like
zip ties and stuff?
[ENGINE REVVING]
Thank you very much.
[DING]
[CHATTER]
INSPECTOR 4: OK.
That's 45.
No leaks, going up to 60.
[MACHINE WHIRRING]
And coming down.
[DING]
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
BEN SORKIN: Are we
doing brake now?
MAN: Yeah.
Sweet.
[INAUDIBLE]
BEN SORKIN: Well, I guess
we solved the problem
from earlier.
So we'll be doing
the brake testing.
And if we pass the brake
test, we're going to race.
So I'm excited.
I mean, Kirk, how do
you feel about this?
KIRK ROBINSON: I’m, I’m
excited, for sure.
INSPECTOR 5: The tires
can't come to a stop,
they have to slide.
You actually have to lock
them up in four-wheel slide
in order to pass brake, OK?
JOE YATES: It's just so
exciting after all this time
working on it.
Especially coming here last
year and not being able to run,
this is pretty exciting.
[ENGINE REVVING]
INSPECTOR 5: Rear wheels
locked, front did not lock.
[BUZZ]
[ENGINE REVVING]
Nothing.
[BUZZ]
KIRK ROBINSON: We didn't
pass the brake test.
Not all the wheels locked
up, partly because the seat's
too far back, so he can't
push hard enough on the pedal,
possibly because of one
our calipers has been
faulting a little, I'm sure.
And we're going to go switch
to our rain tires which
should have less grip.
So hopefully that'll be
better at locking up.
TARIK DZANIC: That's not good.
Release.
KIRK ROBINSON: No, that's fine --
[CHATTER]
Apparently, it's the master
cylinder, not the calipers.
We'll see.
We have some other ones,
which are the wrong size.
But maybe we can
make them work.
BEN SORKIN: We
really want to show
that we are able to compete
to the fullest extent.
So we're going to still try
to get this brake set up.
And then even if we get half
a lap in the endurance race,
we still get points
for qualifying.
So we're going to
shoot for that.
COLEMAN MERCHANT: Our back
brakes already locked up,
so we're halfway there.
We just need to
fix the front ones.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[CHATTER]
Let's lift in three, two, one.
BEN SORKIN: All right.
Time is ticking, boys.
Go.
MAN: Do we need a
fire extinguisher?
MAN: Yeah, grab one.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MAN: If we're not
done, let’s just go to endurance.
MAN: No, no.
We just keep going till
we get the brake test.
MAN: The point is to be
ready to race, right?
MAN: Yeah, but I
kind of want to race.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[BUZZ]
[ENGINE REVVING]
[CHEERING]
MAN: Do the same thing.
MAN: Alright.
[ENGINE WHIRRING]
INSPECTOR 5: No, nothing locked up.
Not in the front.
[BUZZ]
But if you want to,
you can ask Sandy
to see whether or not
there is maybe time
to go over and do a couple
laps over on the endurance.
Because you can stop.
You can stop beautifully,
but you're not locking,
so I can't give you a sticker.
BEN SORKIN: OK.
Sounds good.
I’ll tell my team.
INSPECTOR 5: OK.
KIRK ROBINSON: You
know, you can reasonably
expect there were kind of just
sort of last minute disasters
that occurred.
Overall, I was
very, very impressed
with how well we handled all
of them and all of the issues
that we faced from, you
know, the last minute,
we realized that we had
no front brakes at all
because our master
cylinder was stuck.
We had all kinds of
electrical problems
that we were able to take
care of very quickly.
Ben did a lap of the course.
We got a lap in.
BEN SORKIN: Actually getting in
the car that we built as a team
over the past two years,
being able to hit the startup
sequence, and at the
end of that sequence,
press that green button,
and hear the double-beep,
put my foot to
the pedal and just
take off under its own power
was an exhilarating feeling.
The car really moved well.
It handled better than
I could have expected.
I was zigzagging in
and out of cones,
going through chicanes
doing hairpin turns.
It was just an unbelievable
feeling, just so exhilarating.
I got out of the
car, I was shaking
from almost fear, but
excitement and anxiety,
and, just, I felt
a lot of relief.
We finally did it.
We got to a place
where a lot of people
didn't think we could
get as such a small team.
But we had the people who
were motivated, dedicated.
And we did it.
COLEMAN MERCHANT:
How do you feel?
BEN SORKIN: That was wow.
That was exhilarating.
Um …
Listen, fantastic job all year.
Listen, it worked better than
it did last year, I think.
Huge strides.
You know, this is only just
like so much more to come.
Pumped.
KIRK ROBINSON: To finish--
it's been such a journey.
It’s been insane.
And I don't know.
I've learned so much.
It's just, it's been
an incredible time.
And I've loved
every minute of it.
Even …
SPEAKER: Is he tearing up?
You're tearing up.
TARIK DZANIC: To even get past
electrical, that was something
I wasn't expecting to happen.
No one gets past electrical.
Out of, what, the 32 teams that
are here, seven passed fully.
We were the eighth team. We ended
up placing eighth in dynamic.
So I mean, eight out of 32?
That's a result I'll take any day.
I love this team.
KIRK ROBINSON: The
amount of people
to thank, the list
is just immense.
But certainly, none of this
would have been possible
without the support of the
Princeton community and all
of —- the mechanical
engineering department,
the ORFE department,
the School of Engineering,
the Keller Center,
Andlinger Center.
There's all these different
organizations within Princeton
that have been helping us out,
both financially, with mentors,
finding space, using the shop.
It's such an
incredible opportunity.
And we all learned so much.
It's been a hell of a ride.
It's been phenomenal.
It's been a great experience.
SPEAKER: One, two, three --
ALL: Go Princeton!
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[ENGINE WHIRRING]